in the Bond franchise women exists may
need to have sex with double-oh-seven
then die a violent death no longer now
the heroes of the summer season of spy
capers and thrillers are heroines maybe
soon we might even have a villain saying
we've been expecting for your eyes only
darling
[Music]
it's bond James Bond inevitably followed
by a mini Ferrari which is what must
happen whenever a beloved character has
their ethnicity or gender changed by a
new casting a non latina actress has
withdrawn from playing Maria in West
Side Story Hermione Granger in the Harry
Potter play cannot be black
What nonsense this is we've always had
fluid and creative casting since actors
first trod the boards in ancient Greece
make-believe is at the heart of theater
not political correctness of course a
black woman can play a white man in
Shakespeare as I saw in Julius Caesar at
the bridge and vice versa Idris Elba
would make a fantastic bond colorblind
and gender blind casting must cut every
which way that's showbiz now folks this
is fascinating and one of my bouts as
long as it doesn't get me shot at the
globe have adopted a gender-fluid cast
noma them as wainy who played her my
only granger in the harry potter stage
production of course as you mentioned
was black and many fans assumed the home
Ione was white leading to a JK Rowling
intervention on social media telling her
fans that all she stipulated was that
Hermione had curly hair of course number
went on to win the Olivier Award for
that precise production and so of course
it can be done it's fantastic night bond
when Albert DeSalvo was suggested as
bond of course Anthony Horowitz said he
was too Street before i justed before I
open up to why people don't think it'll
be bond and I just wanna there is a
caution that I would advise all of us to
keep in mind and that is that there are
there are there is under-representation
going on actually on the stage at the
moment and as long as this is done in a
way that doesn't further that
colorblindness and gender blindness
should be the ideal but if it is the
case at the moment that only thirty
percent thirty seven percent of main
characters in Hollywood productions are
women and out of those sixty eight
percent are white then we
just have to be a bit concerned that
this is done in a way that still results
in equitable and fair representation so
if a role was specifically written for
example for a person of a certain
specific gender or ethnicity then it
would probably be just probably be a bit
make a bit more sense in the current
status where we have under
representation to try and cast for that
role first to see them find the answer
Rachel it's a fantasy it's more than 50
years old every man wants to be with
bond every woman wants to be with bond
that is the whole idea this is a man who
has the physical strength to fight over
half a dozen KGB agents then jump in an
aircraft then have a little bit of
ladies and gentlemen under a snow rug
with some beautiful woman who then gets
poisoned by a crazed Korean assassin it
just goes like that much as your support
it's like a statue
well let's accept that it was written at
that time whether he's white or whether
he's black but you cannot have a female
bond that's part of the fantasy and
lastly a bloke looks at Bonnell thinks
god I wish I could fight like him I wish
I could play golf like him I wish I
could fly an aircraft like that you
might get under those let me tell you
about Leo ringer Leo ringer is an actor
who was cast in the Royal Shakespeare
Society production of the fantastic
Follies of mr. H he's a great actor I've
seen him in action myself now he was on
the receiving end of a review by none
other than Quentin let's my old friend
who said that lyrica is too cool to
mature not chinless or daft or funny
enough was he cast because he's black if
so the RSC's plunking approach to
politically correct casting has again
weakened its stage products I suppose
its managers are under pressure from the
Arts Council to tick inclusiveness boxes
but at some point they're going to have
to decide if their core business is
drama or social engineering there's more
in
and then Leo ringer replied to that
saying and this is I want you to listen
carefully in the early years of my
career he said I mainly witnessed actors
of color like myself in stereotypical
roles such as servants and criminals
rather than leading parts let him finish
there was never any casting that could
be considered as inclusive
let's made an extended an unforgivable
racial slur against me and my fellow
accent can I agree
this is about a woman playing
misunderstood my argument I slightly
disagree with Madge as well because I
don't think you should necessarily cast
the person who I knew we want the best
person for the part whether they're
black white male lead bond aside I agree
I mean his lira finger was cast in that
role because just cast the best person
which is why if you want to have a white
person playing Maria if she is the best
person and she's not put Rican she
should be allowed to play the role
Goldfinger I kind of I thought that was
very gracious to seeing she said as an
artist I should have realized that that
rule should vote aside or Tariq which
need of a movie but no but my point is
that you have to be you so you agree
with that that's really good yeah with
things that are FF a Latino if it's a
story about a little email care to get
is a to because there are plenty of
Latino actors and actresses right but
you know my general partners are our
fear is the theater managers job to give
us good drama also to be socially
engineering and that's not talked about
a clunker this is my approach to
diversity he's got probably smiled you
have
playing a man when this cranky blokes
around and vice versa why did it make
Street Fighter it moves might headlines
my issue is the assumption that if you
cast the black person as Leo ringer was
cast the assumption by Quentin Lex he
was only cars to be politically correct
ah the assumption that was not Jeff he
was the best person which is the world
Shakespeare so we can click on
historical accuracy was a lot of drama
in that thing Troy okay that yeah but
it's supposed to be convincing in that
the city supposedly blonde blue-eyed
warriors a black man can play a white
woman on stage which is what we're
seeing I saw Julius Caesar where Casca
was played by black woman he was a white
man I I my argument is a white man
should be able to play a black woman
it's got to cut though so we can't sit
around and say we have to come according
to greed I don't you now start giving
the few roles that the designer them to
my actors you're not achieving that
that's true the movies okay